whenever he was at the door I bust him
in and he came inside my thought process
it was just another dude coming in to
work out so I didn't mind I didn't think
of anything out of that
as soon as he was approaching me I
pushed him I said bro what the f are you
doing get away from me stop trying to
touch me he started chasing me around
the bench and we ended up on the other
side of the gym
I'm grateful that she came forward I
know that her story is going to be an
inspiration to other women
my advice would be to never give up my
parents always told me in life to never
give on anything and that's one thing I
always kept to my mind when I was
fighting him as as long as you don't
give up you fight back you show him that
you are strong that you are one that
you're able to fight back and survive
this and get out of the situation I
believe it's possible